the Joe Rogan experience well how about
cyborg when Michael venom page hit him
with that knee whoo that's one that
makes you you makes you [ __ ] your
whole body tightens up you like howdy
how do you get somebody scold like you
know much force you have to hit somebody
with like that crazy think of all the
fights you've seen we've never seen that
I've never seen that think about this
when something you everybody's been hit
on the head or something fell on your
head and it's a edge of something and
just that pain yeah I can't imagine what
that pain is like that's that's bone
yeah well I don't want to see it open
I'm just like I looked over there like
that screen brightened up and well yeah
but Cosmo Alexandra did - that's crazy -
one punch broke like eight bones in his
face yeah like it's not this is not for
the light hearted man I get a lot of
people like I'm not I'm not a sage hater
but I'm not a sage lover you know what I
mean but like I don't wish that on
anybody I don't wish that on anybody
either and I don't I don't like that
matchup I didn't like that matchup at
all I was like what are they doing that
is a that's a world champion striker
Cosmo is a [ __ ] bad man he's a bad
man he lights people on fire yeah you
know and in him at 185 pounds with no
weight cutting and that's one of things
that he said about that fight how good
he felt like he didn't have to cut any
weight you see how thick [ __ ] full he
looked it wasn't depleted and dehydrated
and everything like that and that is
just not sages
bring it back to the beginning but look
at this look how thick he is - like have
you seen cosmos fights before I remember
when he fought John Wayne par and lion
fight I mean but John Wayne par is a
multiple time world champion and a
skilful guy and he managed to avoid like
the big power shots like this and didn't
get hurt but it's also Cosmo having a
chance to punch you with MMA gloves
right - with the majority of his career
a fog Muay Thai boom I mean that is a
crazy punch everything's behind that
it's and it's like
this kid is just not ready for this yeah
he's just not ready for this as much as
he has experience in karate and you know
he had some good MMA fights against some
you know good fighters this is not a
good fighter that's an elite world-class
striker right and you know you're
fighting him with little gloves on in a
ring and you're you're mixed martial
arts game is primarily a striking mm-hmm
yep yeah you have a big disadvantage
huge enormous disadvantage
I'd like what one is doing though I
really do I like what they're doing I
thought that's interesting too that they
made him fight in a ring well I don't
know how many events one does in a ring
versus does in a cage but the dynamics
shift radically when you get caught you
get cornered you know like that's one of
the cool things about the Bellator cage
yes it's circular there's no corner
corner yeah yeah but that you know and
you see a boxing ring like that yeah
that's especially again with Cosmo like
yes that's where he spent most of his
time like all of his time it's a
different environment and cutting that
off is so much easier and for a guy
who's who knows how to do that it's it's
almost like sage was set up I'm not
saying they set up yeah this is a bad
situation he didn't have I mean I guess
he didn't have to take the fight I don't
know I should say I don't know how they
do their matchmaking I don't know if
it's like like the UFC kind of forces
fights on people right they let you know
like you take this fight or you know
we'll probably call you yeah yeah it's
up to you but if you want a career in
the UFC
you take fights when you get them but
like when you see fighters in boxing
they get if they have a really good
manager they the manager knows who the
guy you're gonna fight is and says okay
Eve this guy is good but you can beat
him and this is what I like about this
style he's gonna he's gonna challenge
you in a couple of areas but overall
you're a better fighter than than him
but it'll give you a challenge and we're
trying to build your record up to get
you a title shot and you know maybe
you'd be nine to no 10 and no 11 to no
12 no and then you know you get to a
certain level and they go okay we're
ready to fight for a title and then it
would be this big promotion II had words
you know 17 and oh you know 16 knockouts
and it shows your highlight reel like
this is some
that big management this is the reason
why it exists in boxing it's actually
smart because it's part of the
development of a fighter for every John
Jones if I could just step in the
Octagon it 21 years old and start
[ __ ] people up there's so many young
fighters that could be world champions
but then they run into elite competition
early in their career and get [ __ ] up
and then the the dream kind of drifts
away from them
yeah if air gets puts in putting them
early yep that's that's a problem and
unnecessarily in my in my opinion
[Applause]